im studio ist jetzt der profiler markt
die hofmann hatte hofmann wir haben es
gerade gehört ein unfassbarer fall ein
mann ein junger mann hat das ganze leben
noch vor sich und zieht los und tötet
hintereinander fünf menschen aus
eifersucht wahrscheinlich wie wir auch
gerade gehört haben wie schnell kennen
aus eifersucht mord werden
leider muss man sagen dass ein satz wie
beispielsweise wenn du dich trends bring
ich dich um muss man leider ernst nehmen
wenn man sich die fälle anschaut
schaut man in die kriminalstatistik
stellt man fest dass ungefähr die zahl
schwankt pro jahr so ungefähr zwischen
120 und 150 frauen die im jahr durch
ihren partner oder ex-partner getötet
werden das heißt ungefähr drei frauen
pro woche werden durch ihren partner
oder ex-partner meistens in trennungs
konflikten getötet und das sind nur die
vollendeten tötung wenn man die
versuchten tötung hinzuzählt dann
verdoppelt sich die zahl nochmal
ungefähr das passiert also fast jeden
tag und wenn man dann auch häusliche
gewalt vergewaltigung gefährliche
körperverletzung nötigung wenn man alle
anderen formen der gewalt noch quasi mit
dazu zählt dann sind wir schnell bei
fällen von mehr als 100.000 pro jahr
das heißt gewalt in partnerschaften ist
etwas sehr häufiges manchmal kommt es
dabei auch zu tötungsdelikten man muss
ganz klar sagen dass das zuhause für
viele frauen kein sicherer ort ist
manche wissen dass auch weil die partner
lange zeit gewalttätig sind
manche wissen das nicht weil die partner
immer nett und freundlich und liebevoll
waren bis zu dem tag oder dem moment der
trennung und dann kommt es erst zu
dieser gewalt entladung aber das zuhause
ist für viele frauen kein sicherer ort
und leute angst vor eingriffen
terroranschlägen und flugzeugabstürzen
sie unterschätzen aber trennungen
trennungen sind wenn man sich die zahlen
anschaut gefährliche situationen und wie
kommt eine person in einen solchen
blutrausch loszuziehen und fünf menschen
ineinander zu erschießen
ja das ist schon ganz beachtlich denn er
sie waren ja verliebt sie waren zusammen
sie hatten eine gemeinsame
lebensperspektive die magie des
augenblicks das verliebtsein sind im
moment kennt man eigentlich keine
probleme
er wollte mit ihr den rest seines lebens
verbringen ja und dann einige monate
später hat er mutmaßlich sie getötet und
ihre gesamte familie
was ist zwischen diesen beiden momenten
passiert zwischen dem absoluten
verliebtsein und er will sie heiraten
bis hin zu er will sie vernichten oder
oder ihr leben nehmen und das ihrer
gesamten familie
es gibt ein wort was ganz erheblichen
beitrag leistet um diese verbrechen zu
verstehen oder erklären zu können was
leider in kaum einem psychiatrischen
diagnosen manual vorkommt und auch in
den meisten ausbildungen keine rolle
spielt es gibt zwei psychiater zwei
professoren die das aber betonen und
haben sich lange mit ihm mit intensiven
beschäftigt also die tötung eines eine
sex oder oder aktuellen partners
meistens der mann der seine frau oder
ex-frau der ex-freundin tötet und
professor rainer talent professor
andreas marneros kommen beide zu dem
fazit dass kränkung ein ganz zentrales
wort ist eine kränkung ist eine sagen
wir tiefe verletzungen der seele die
sich nie explosiv in dem moment entlädt
in dem moment reagieren leute mal cool
aber es staut sich an und nicht selten
führen solche taten dann so ganz
schlimmen gewalttaten und ich würde
sogar so weit gehen dass es kaum eine
größere gewalt hat der letzten jahre
gibt von germanwings absturz bis hin zu
terroranschlägen bis hin zu amokläufen
bis hin zu beziehungstaten es gibt kaum
eine tat wo nicht eine kränkung eine
rolle spielt und um diese geschichte mal
ein bisschen zu rekonstruieren
es scheint schon in der beziehung ein
gewisses ungleichgewicht gegeben zu
haben das heißt zwischen diesen beiden
polen dem verliebtsein und und dem töten
woran es letztlich endete
dazwischen scheint es schon in der
beziehung gewisse kränkung gegeben zu
haben vielleicht sie wollte ein anderes
leben leben er wollte gern zu hause
bleiben sie wollte feiern gehen das
heißt vielleicht gab es viele kleine
momente die die ihn schon gekränkt haben
oftmals ist es so dass diese täter ihren
selbstwert an die beziehung koppeln nach
dem motto ich bin wertvoll weil du mich
liebst oder wenn du mich liebst das
bedeutet aber im umkehrschluss auch wenn
du mich verlässt bin ich nichts mehr
wert also sie sie machen ihren
selbstwert vollständig abhängig von
dieser beziehung das ist die einzige
säule auf der das gesamte selbstbild
ruth und steht und wenn diese säule
wegbricht dann zieht es den wortwörtlich
den teppich unter dem boden weg und
sieben sie sind lebens bankrott und
diese kränkung beginnen oft schon in der
beziehung und dann irgendwann kommt
kommt die trennung und am tag der
trennung hatte das wahrscheinlich gar
nicht konfrontiert oder realisiert er
hat ihr ja noch nachrichten schrieben
lass uns treffen lass uns reden
hat er sich gedacht das ist temporär
vielleicht ist eine phase aber die die
wird schon wieder zu mir zurückkommen
aber je mehr sie geantwortet hat nein
das ist das war's das ist ende und dann
hat sie neuen partner das ist noch mal
eine weitere kränkung und ist auch nicht
irgendein partner so waren erfolgreicher
eishockeyspieler am tag vor dem mord
wurde er noch man of the match at quasi
und eishockey titel gewonnen
ich meine jeder muss doch zugeben oder
sagen dass wenn man denen die verlobte
oder den verlobten sehen würde wenn sie
ihren verlobten mit mister germany in
einer bar treffen natürlich verletzt
dass und crank das aber wir haben
meistens noch genug impulskontrolle und
morden nicht aus diesen gründen aber für
diese leute den zieht es den teppich
unter den füßen weg sie sehen ihren
selbstwert ruiniert sie sehen keine
perspektive mehr keine hoffnung mehr
und dann fährt er hin und dann wird er
noch vom vater weggeschickt noch eine
demütigung dann sagt sie noch ich hab
dich zwei mal betrogen und schleich dich
was die österreichische charmante
variante für verpiss dich ist und das
kann dann eine demütigung zu viel seien
aber um diese taten zu verstehen muss
man nicht nur die minuten vor der tat
anschauen sondern auch die jahre vor der
tat denn oft liegen die kränkung oder
die momente die in summe dazu geführt
haben weit zurück und dann kommt es
manchmal zu dieser ungebremsten gewalt
entladung die tötung des ex partners und
in diesem fall auch der gesamten familie
können sie denn kurz zusammenfassen wie
sie das profil des kitzbühel killers
beschreiben würden jetzt nach dem was
sie alles wissen ja in vielerlei
hinsicht eifersucht kränkungen tötung
des beziehungs partners ist das eine
beziehungstat wie man sie fast täglich
oder zumindest wöchentlich in
deutschland beobachten kann das diesem
fall ja auch so besonders macht ist dass
er fünf personen getötet hat also die
gesamte familie dafür gibt es zwei
wesentliche erklärung und das kann ich
nicht beantworten zumindest nicht ohne
mit ihm gesprochen zu haben das kann nur
er beantworten
es könnte natürlich sein dass er dem
vater getötet hat um den mord an ihr
überhaupt zu ermöglichen er musste ja
durch die haustür musste ja sozusagen an
an denen vorbei das ist eine möglichkeit
dass es quasi mittel zum zweck war um an
sie heranzukommen die zweite möglichkeit
ist das ist einfach eine ungebremste
geballten ladung war und zum profil kann
man vier dinge ganz kurz sagen erstens
er macht seinen eigenen selbstwert stark
von der beziehung abhängig zwei sehr
impulsiv das heißt erscheint nicht in
der lage sein mit
enttäuschung oder rückschlägen umgehen
zu können wir alle lernen verletzten
hätten liebeskummer aber wir morgen
nicht
das heißt diese die diese fehlende
fähigkeit diese negativen emotionen auch
zu verarbeiten diese impulsivität
scheint auf jeden fall da zu sein
er verwechselt liebe mitbesitz das merkt
man auch immer wieder bei stalkern dass
sie das wort liebe mit dem wort besitz
verwechseln sie wollen nicht lieben sie
wollen eigentlich besitzen und im
zweifel ist dann lieber soll sie tot
sein und keinen gehören als nicht mehr
zu gehören das heißt sie verwechseln
liebe mit besitz und last but not least
sehe ich ihn aber nicht als
psychopathische monster sondern wie es
auch im gutachten der psychiaterin
geschildert wurde
die tat wird er bereuen das hat er im
rausch der emotionen gemacht und ich
kann mir gut vorstellen oder ich traue
ihm zu dass er dafür reue empfindet und
dass er auch nach dem gefängnis sich
möglicherweise rehabilitieren kann und
vielleicht noch sein leben in
irgendeiner art in eine bahn lenken die
abnahme ohne gewalt auskommt